في ضواحي زابوريا حديقه العاب بلا اطفال
في ساحه بدون طلاب هرب الكثير منهم لمدن
اخرى
ارينا تدرس ماده علوم الحاسوب لمئه وخمسين
طالبا تعطي ثلاثه حصص يوميه وحيده في قاعه
صف فارغه عشره طلاب يشاركون عن بعد في هذه
الحصه
تذكرهم صفارات الانذار بالحرب وتقطع حصتهم
استمعوا الي يا اطفال دوت صفارات الانذار
الان ارجوكم اسمعوني اولئك الذين في مكان
لا يوجد فيه انذار يرجى البقاء في مكانكم
اذا كنتم في مدينه فيها سفارات الانذار
يوجد توجه للاختباء في مكان امن اتسمعونني
اين ترى في هذه الحصه فرصه لها للحفاظ على
مستوى طلابها ولكنها تواجه مصاعب عديده
هناك مشاكل كثيره في التعلم عن بعد لا ارى
الطلاب لذا فانا لا اعرفهم جيدا لا اعرف
شيئا عنهم ولا اعرف اهتماماتهم وهوايتهم
لذلك لا يمكن استخدام ذلك في تعليمهم
يواجه الطلاب ايضا مشاكل بالاضافه
للصعوبات التعليميه لا يوجد تواصل بين
الطلاب وهو ملحوظ للغايه يبقون طوال الوقت
في المنزل اطفال هذا الجيل ليس لديهم
اصدقاء لان المدرسه الابتدائيه كانت تدرس
عن بعد بسبب فيروس كورونا واليوم اصبح
التعليم عن بعد مجددا بسبب الحرب اوكي
باشا تبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات في الصف
الاخير من المرحله الابتدائيه
احببت هذه المنصه لكنها ليست كما في
الحياه الواقعيه لانه من الصعب جدا القيام
بالواجب المنزلي اثناء التعلم عبر
الانترنت هذا لاننا نتشتت كثيرا اثناء
الدراسه عام صعب بالنسبه لها تقضيه في
المنزل مع والديها ليصبح التعليم عن بعد
نافذتها الصغيره في زمن الحرب لتكوين
صداقات افتراضيه نعم تعرفت فقط على
اسمائهم من خلال الحصه عبر الانترنت اعرف
انهم جميعا لطفاء للغايه واود ان نكون
اصدقاء
لكنها تحتفظ بالامل بان تعود لصفوف
مدرستها من جديد في العام المقبل